ça bouge on va commencer par un sprint
c'est ici au centre chorégraphique
c'est de la danse et du sport du sport
et la danse bref c'est une performance
est parti que se passe-t-il et que
reste-t-il lorsqu'on va jusqu'à
l'épuisement un deuxième souffle la
renaissance performance de maeva conchie
mise en scène et chorégraphié par
emmanuelle vo dinh sprint c'est ce soir
et demain 20h au centre chorégraphique
national de caen normandie et maintenant
on se passe c'est du théâtre de l'eso
c'est au tour de vire avec le théâtre du
préau création du collectif denis ciac
pour le festival à dos de vire spasmes
décrit la décomposition puis la
recomposition d'une famille après la
mort d'un enfant parent est avec qui y
est la pièce intègre trois ados de la
région de vire cobayes tu peux venir
elle sera jouée ce soir à la perelle
demain à condé en normandie et jeudi à
domfront emploierait et maintenant va
ralentir avec du théâtre suisse ici même
au panthéon
guy delamotte écrire aujourd'hui c'est
important on sait qu'il ya du molière en
ses quais du shakespeare on sait que
tous les grands auteurs sont joués mais
on met pas assez l'accent sur ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui et c'est le cas avec
marie aujourd'hui
bah oui disons que au panta théâtre on
travaille on pourrait dire
essentiellement autour des écritures
contemporaines tout autour des traces de
pas peut-être trois gars des traces de
pneus mais les pneus ne dirons rien j'ai
travaillé sur le polar en tant qu'auteur
tout d'un coup je me disais mais quand
on allume la télévision en ce moment il
n'y a que des séries policières à foison
le texte a été écrit en 2012
et le constat aujourd'hui est toujours
le même donc et donc du coup j'étais
partie de ça et je me disais aussi nous
on a un voyeurisme quand on voit un fait
divers dans la presse et je me dis tiens
il est où le curseur entre moi qui
allume la télé le soir et qui regarde
une série policière un peu sordide et le
lendemain matin je vais lire dans le
train ou dans mon transport en commun un
fait divers un peu sordide et puis je
vais vouloir des détails
qu'est ce qu'il en est du format du
théâtre par rapport à cette question
la messe et les space w123 s'appelle
mercedes-benz w123 parce qu'on retrouve
le cadavre d'une jeune fille dans le
coffre d'une voiture
je suis las mercedes d'hubert le
bas-côté d'une route de campagne
je suis la scène de crime
si le théâtre un intérêt un seul
peut-être c'est d'essayer de décrypter
le monde d'en rendre compte
et peut-être que ça nous permettra en le
comprenant un peu mieux peut-être de
mieux vivre aussi la radio à fond on
entend pas très bien il lui dit venir
dans la voiture via freddy là le tamil
efforts puisque en plus dans la pièce on
va aborder les problèmes des réseaux
sociaux où la fed devra pouvoir filmer
facilement quelque chose le diffuser sur
le net
donc c'est un texte qui a été aussi
écrit pour ses quinze vingt ans parce
que ça c'est une histoire d'adolescents
qui a mal tourné donc voilà
de concert demain soir la rumba à 20h
matty james
et maintenant le gars de lion-sur-mer le
révérend birman demain soir également à
19h à la rumba à caen c'est du punk
en fait une question patrick head ou
punk non jacques nous sommes à la
renaissance à mondeville pour une
rencontre insolite qui aura lieu ce soir
à 20h30 s'agit de toi alors j'entends
aurier à la il s'agit de musique de
chant de pygmées qu'il chanta près des
grilles et d'après de la chasse kamel a
écouté la retranscrire de manière
musicale et qu'il a ensuite orchestré
pour un orchestre à cordes pour qu'on
puisse jouer ensemble ces chants qu'ils
imaginent ne sont pas harmonisées
en fait ça fait 17 ans que je travaille
avec eux voilà on est dans un rapport de
confiance musicale très fort donc là
c'est la rencontre de deux grandes
traditions tradition de leur caisse de
l'écriture et puis la tradition de
l'oralité
ça va prendre le fracas des pygmées
travailler avec des enquêtes comme ça
donc eu des 40 vivent souvent tôt à
bangui pour dire aux gens que nous on a
travaillé mais encaissent le mur les
prophéties ni un signe de reconnaissance
est une reconnaissance pour la peau leur
musique
on
oh
voilà jacques j'espère que vous avez
tout compris à ces rencontres insolites
ce soir à la renaissance à battante